is when's the last time we saw move this
significant in bonds I mean they're
gaining right i mean this flight to
safety people are piling right to
Treasuries yields are dropping prices
are rising it's been the biggest move
since 2011 so far today and there are
lot of questions about whether these are
short positions capitulating whether
this is people basically saying look the
US economy is going to be slowed down by
the economic slowdown globally is it is
it Ebola fears is it the oil prices
which are which is sort of putting a cap
at how much oil and Ebola yes I'm gonna
go yes there you've got to imagine I
mean we were just talking about this I
mean us is not the most sophisticated
medical system out there and yet we're
unable to contain Ebola among health
workers and it releases and people have
gotten it I think you know it's it's
it's interesting to talk about the
spread of this disease and how we
contain it it should be pointed out that
two people have gotten it here in the US
both of them are we're dealing with with
it with a patient that was in the most
severe stages right before death of
Ebola and the people he spent time with
in dallas right beforehand that he
probably lived with and slept with
haven't gotten it yet oh that is fair
but having said that i was looking
through some analysts notes and just a
report on oil prices from francisco
Blancas bakery garlic actually cited
Ebola as one of the drivers pushing oil
prices lower I mean not a direct link
per se but as one of the many factors
speaking of oil in fact is actually come
back it's rebounded and is now firmer
right now so that might be a sign of
things kind of stabilizing as we've seen
equities have kind of bottom for now and
even the Treasury yield has come back a
little bit too I mean I think they
realistically there is kind of a floor
to how low stock markets can go and how
low risk your asks can go cuz the
stimulus is ongoing there's that may a
Florida how low stock markets can go
right yeah I think I think it's I think
it's so interesting to see the Treasury
markets basically are illustrating
everyone's running for the exits and
it's kind of a stronger illustration
than we see currently in equity market